les amis l'heure est grave je me
baladais comme tous les jours sur
youtube après avoir tapé squeeze dans la
barre de recherche parce que j'ai un ego
surdimensionné je me fais des fellations
chaque soir avant de me coucher je
comptais mais vu hélas youtube monnaie
que ça représentait lorsque soudainement
je suis tombé sur une déclaration
d'amour quelqu'un même caisse est arrivé
quelqu'un à mon enfant johnny crying
squeeze je t'aime pour de vrai regarde
moi ce si joli visage
je suis tout ouïe johnny crying mois
- j'aime beaucoup squeeze dim en plus le
gars l'homme qui fait des vidéos pour
jouer au jeu moins jeunes aiment
beaucoup ce qu'on a c'est une fille fait
pas du tout ici est de rome et des
chroniques
il est aussi humoristique
est ce que quelqu'un j'en suis à ce
bruit et drôle est ce que quelqu'un a
déjà entendu quelqu'un dire excusez des
drôles in est chouette naegeli il est
joli
moi j'aime beaucoup squeeze aujourd'hui
je mets le parfum pour lui je veux
sentir bon pour squeeze mon ami johnny
je peux pas senti un train des vidéos au
nom johnny to both admirateurs s'est
fait mal je sens bon pour toi squeezing
un squeeze est ce que tu veux sentir
avec tourner cette bonne odeur
tu sens bon johnny mon je trouve mes
amis à moi dit que je cuisinais pas joli
pathé ami john il faut que suivent ce
que la majorité pense de moi il dit
squeeze et l'est il est très moche
- jeudi squeeze est très beau et très
élégant et gentlemen squeeze si tu
regardes mont vidéo je veux te donner un
bisou
j'ai jamais embrassé quelqu'un jeudi
mais si tu veux me député la bouche ce
sera avec grand plaisir je veux de
donner un bijou pour toi squeeze j'ai
compris ce quiz bisous je donne bobbies
ou un squeeze parce que je t'aime ça va
trop vite
qu'est ce qu'on doit penser que ça ok
les amis c'était johnny crying un homme
qui possède 26 mille [ __ ] d'abonnés il
nous a clairement fait une déclaration
d'amour nous a clairement dit qu'il nous
aimait qui voulait qu'il se passe
quelque chose entre une ou johnny je
suis un homme très facile mais
j'aimerais quand même en savoir un peu
plus sur toi je ne pouvais voir si tu
possèdes d'autres vidéos
oui oh mon dieu quelle connerie johnny
type bien pu faire au nom seveso
parfaite pour tout savoir de l'homme de
votre vie
bonjour aujourd'hui si johnny trade
center normes aux pv en beach et tu peux
arrêter
aujourd'hui je vais vous dire vin chaud
sur moi noir j'aime les patates
le numéro 5 j'aime le bâti chinois set
monfils
tu n'avais qu'une seule chose à faire
jeudi ses côtés jusqu'à 20 sont des
troupes et 7 j'aime jouer à des jeux
il veut qu'on croit qu'il est comme nous
il connaît les huit noms le neuf
johnny numéro 9 et 6 numéros size
j'aime mettre mon nez
dans la ville chi minh une [ __ ] mais
j'ai tellement de vidéos
dieu sait que ça il ya le feu
elia lot il y à la terre et il ya le vin
est il ya moi le cinquième élément
johnny tu n secteur nord mon pv un but
yep je veux sentir la babylone avec
tournée mais quel ton [ __ ] [ __ ] date
edf a choisi la terre ont bien fait se
débarrasser des peaux noires rapidement
oui à prendre ou john il suffit de
prendre au pétrole mais leur nature et
de la frottée légère marchand mais oui
oui mais c'est tellement évident à
johnny crying en vélo de l'amour
tu n'as rien à envier à dicaprio johnny
tu meurs la carte au trésor
oh
bonjour mon ami je suis ici dans les
marais salle dégueulasse et puisque
babil oui mon ami regard c'est que j'ai
trouvé
j'ai trouvé des pichous pipi joutes une
fumigation johnny t'es sur que c'est pas
à brest l'histoire d'octave il a deux
minutes avant j'ai trouvé une caverne
qui contenait décryptage badila nyanda y
avait des scolaires il y avait dix
connaissent rien de trop mal de l'ordre
y avaient diffamant corps momifié je
voyais le même là encore été dit
je n'ai je sais que tu es obsédé par les
tétées mais tu ne peux pas t'aider le
lait d'un mamelons si c'est en fait un
squelette et je crois j'ai trouvé un
tirage spécial e siècle personne n'a
jamais vu un homme de courage et d croit
donc qu'il a mis dans une situation
évoluer babylonienne comment as tu pu
trouver une pyramide dans de l'eau où tu
habilles et johnny au bonjour mon ami tu
sois là quoi des fois il faut se
regarder que vous voyez là but sur sa
brouille est ouvert aux aigles essaie de
se mettre une bouteille de gin par la
braguette moutons avec des visages
handball et johnny crée déjà froissé ou
je peux se voter comment pratiquer la
beauté voilà ça peut marcher
je ne fais pas des gros plans comme ça 1
2 3 as un bon
je n'étais pas en forme là sur la fin
c'est l'heure du verdict tard il a les
yeux bleus ils jouent aux jeux vidéo
c'est un aventurier il a une grosse
barbe john et j'accepte a été posée
j'attends plus de moi